>> THE INVESTIGATION WAS NOT
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT, JIM COMEY
TOLD THE PRESIDENT THAT THREE
TIMES IN THE MEETINGS THAT IT
NEVER HAS BEEN THE CENTER OF THE
INVESTIGATION, NOR IS IT THE
ROLE OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
TRY TO GET AN INDICTMENT OF THE
PRESIDENT.
HIS ROLE WAS VERY CLEAR TO SEE
IF THERE WAS ANY CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY AMONG THE CAMPAIGN.
>> I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE BASIS
WAS FOR THAT STATEMENT BY RUDY
GIULIANI, AND WHETHER IT WAS
JUST AN OFFHAND VIEW BY ONE OF
THE ATTORNEYS WITH THE FEDERAL
COUNCIL, OR WHETHER IT WAS A
PRONOUNCEMENT BY THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL HIMSELF.
>> Bret: IT WELL, THE BREAKING
NEWS TODAY, RUDY GIULIANI
TELLING OUR OWN FOX NEWS'
JOHN ROBERTS THAT THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL FOLLOW DOJ GUIDANCE THAT
THE PRESIDENT WILL NOT BE
INDICTED.
ACCORDING TO GIULIANI, MUELLER
HAS NO CHOICE.
AND THEY ARE OBVIOUSLY PUSHING
FOR THIS TO COME TO A
CONCLUSION.
WHAT DOES THIS ALL MEAN, AND
LET'S PUT OUT WITH THE SENATE
PUT OUT.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL HERE IN
NEW YORK.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY ARI FLEISCHER.
KAREN HEALEY BURNS, AND BILL
McGURN, MAINSTREAM COLUMNIST
FOR "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL."
OKAY, ARI.
YOUR TAKE ON GIULIANI AND WHAT
HE SAID TODAY.
>> WELL IT SIGNIFICANT BUT, NO
PRESIDENT'S HOME FREE AND
NEITHER ARE THE STAFF ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO WORKED WITH ON THE
CAMPAIGN.
WE HAVE TO WAIT FOR BOB MUELLER
AND ONLY THEN ARE PEOPLE HOME
FREE.
IT IS SIGNIFICANT, BECAUSE OF
RUDY GIULIANI IS RIGHT, AND I'D
LIKE TO HEAR THIS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, THEN IT'S
A SIGNIFICANT SIGH OF RELIEF IN
THE LEGAL SENSE.
AS WE ALL KNOW FROM WHAT
BILL CLINTON WENT THROUGH IF
THIS IS A POLITICAL EXERCISE IN
ADDITION TO A LEGAL EXERCISE.
THE REAL JEOPARDY COMES FROM
CONGRESS AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THINK'S
THINK CRIMES ARE COMMITTED IT
WILL HURT THE PRESIDENT.
HAVING SAID ALL THAT, I STILL
SEE NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
I DON'T THINK THERE HAS BEEN
COLLUSION FROM THE START AND
PARTICULAR THE THE MOST
PERNICIOUS WOULD HAVE BEEN
INVOLVEMENT IN THE TRUMP PEOPLE
OF HACKING HILLARY AND PODESTA'S
EMAILS AND THAT'S WHAT THIS WAS
ALL ABOUT.
>> Bret: A TEAM SUBPOENAED THE
SOCIAL MEDIA DIRECTOR FOR ROGER
STONE TODAY, AND WE ALSO HAVE
THE RELEASE OF SOME SENATE
DOCUMENTS.
IT PUT IT IN PERSPECTIVE FOR US.
>> THE SENATE DOCUMENTS REALLY
CONFIRMED WHAT THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY SAID IT WHICH WAS THAT
RUSSIA MEDDLED IN THE ELECTION
TO HELP DONALD TRUMP.
NOW THAT'S DIFFERENT FROM THE
HAAS, COW'S ASSESSMENT, THE
HOUSE ASSESSMENT OF COURSE THE
PRESIDENT WAS CHEERING ON.
>> Bret: SENATOR LANKFORD TRY
TO STRENGTHEN STOMACH STRAIGHTEN
THAT OUT ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE IN
THE COMMITTEES.
BUT GO AHEAD.
>> I THINK THE BIGGER POINT IS
THAT THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION
CONTINUES, THE PRESIDENT IS
HANGING OVER HIS ADMINISTRATION
CERTAINLY AND HAS EXPRESSED
FRUSTRATIONS WITH THAT.
I'M INTERESTED TO SEE HOW THE
PUBLIC REACTS THE LONGER THIS
GOES ON.
YOU HAVE SEEN IN POLLING, A
SLIGHT DIP IN PEOPLE'S
PERCEPTIONS OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
YOU'VE SEEN REPUBLICANS COME UP
BY A LARGE MARGIN, REALLY
OPPOSING THAT.
AND YOU'VE SEEN CANDIDATES
RUNNING FOR OFFICE ON THE TICKET
RUNNING FOR OFFICE ON THE TICKE
TICKET, INVOKING THE PRESIDENT'S
LANGUAGE THAT THIS IS A WITCH
HUNT.
THE PRESIDENT RESHUFFLED HIS
LEGAL TEAM BECAUSE HE DIDN'T
THINK THAT HE WAS GETTING THE
BEST ADVICE, AND HE WANTED TO
HAVE A MORE COMBATIVE NATURE
WITH THE SPECIAL COUNSEL, SO WE
WILL SEE HOW GIULIANI HANDLES
THIS IN THE NEW SPACE.
>> Bret: BILL?
>> I THINK IT WAS GOOD IN TWO
WAYS.
ONE, I THINK IS GOOD THE
COMMITTEES RELEASE THEIR
FINDINGS BECAUSE OF THE ROOT OF
OUR SYSTEM IS POLITICAL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND AT WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
NEED IS TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
THE LONGER WE GO ON AND COME TO
MORE QUESTIONS WE HAVE ABOUT OUR
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE AND SO
FORTH, AND IT SEEMS LESS
EVIDENCE ABOUT DONALD TRUMP, SO
THAT'S ONE SIDE.
THE OTHER THING I THINK,
MR. GIULIANI'S COMMENTS WERE
GOOD.
THINK ABOUT THIS, THE PROSECUTOR
WHO ESSENTIALLY WORKS FOR THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT GUIDELINES,
AND THAT IS A NEWS STORY.
I FIND IT INCREDIBLE.
I THINK THE PROPER VENUE FOR
MOST OF THIS IS CONGRESS AND
IT'S AMAZING TO ME THAT CONGRESS
HAS BEEN STONEWALLED IN ITS
PURSUIT OF MANY OF THESE, AND
IT'S TAKEN A BACKSEAT.
WE KIND OF LOOK TO CRIMINALIZE
POLITICAL BEHAVIOR.
THE FIRST ACCOUNTABILITY SHOULD
BE UP TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
THROUGH THEIR ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES.
TO BE >> Bret: THERE'S A LOT
WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE START OF
THE INVESTIGATION AND THERE IS A
LOT THAT JUST DOES NOT ADD UP
WITH THAT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
LOOKING AT IT, BUT CAPITOL HILL
HASN'T COME TO THAT CONCLUSION,
EITHER.
>> AND TO QUOTE CHARLES CRAY
HOLMER, THIS IS ALL SMOKE AND NO
FIRE.
THAT'S WHAT WE KEEP TRACED
STOMACH CHASING.
I KEEP COMING BACK TO THE CORE
RATIO, DID ANYONE WORK WITH THE
EMAILS OR WORK WITH RICKY      W
EMAILS OR WORK WITH RICKY      K
EMAILS OR WORK WITH RICKY      L
EMAILS OR WORK WITH RICKY      A
EMAILS OR WORK WITH RICKY      S
EMAILS OR WORK WITH RICKY      T
EMAILS OR WORK WITH RICKY      O
DISSEMINATE THEM?
IF THE ANSWER IS NO, WHAT ARE WE
DOING?
WHERE IS THIS GOING?
INDICTING PEOPLE FOR A FINANCIAL
FRAUD AND OTHER THINGS THAT HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
FINE, BUT IT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
>> Bret: ANYTHING IN YOUR
ASSESSMENT OF THAT TRANSCRIPT OF
2500 PAGES FROM THE TRUMP TOWER
THAT STRUCK YOU THAT
DONALD TRUMP JR. DIDN'T KNOW
WHETHER HIS DAD KNEW OR NOT?
>> THE INTEREST IN THIS MEETING,
OF COURSE, IS BECAUSE OF THE
QUESTION OF COLLUSION.
WHETHER TRUMP ASSOCIATES WERE
AMENABLE OR OPEN, RECEPTIVE TO
ANY HELP FROM RUSSIAN AGENTS.
AND WHAT WE DON'T KNOW IS WHAT
DONALD TRUMP JR. KNEW OR DIDN'T
KNOW.
WE THOUGHT IT WAS INTERESTING
THAT HE SAID HE CAN REALLY TALK
TO HIS FATHER ABOUT IT.
POUR IN VARIOUS EXCHANGES, AND
HE DIDN'T KNOW OR COULDN'T
RECALL.
I THINK THIS PROVIDES A MORE
DETAILED ASSESSMENT OF THAT
MEETING, BUT STILL, I THINK
THERE ARE LOTS OF QUESTIONS.
I THINK THE BROADER QUESTION OF
COURSE IS, WHEN WILL THIS WRAP
UP AND WHAT WILL COME OF IT?
YOU'VE HAD LOTS OF INDICTMENTS
ON RUSSIAN MEDDLING OF COURSE,
BUT ON THE ISSUE OF COLLUSION,
YOU HAVE LOTS OF PEOPLE ASKING
WHEN THIS WILL BE ANSWERED.
>> Bret: I WANT TO DO AROUND
ON NORTH KOREA.
>> WHILE MY THING IS, SPECIAL
COUNSEL IS CORRUPT AND THERE'S A
REASON WE ARE AT THE STAGE AND
FINDING NO EVIDENCE GOING ON, SO
IT WOULD BE NICE IF WE GOT TO A
CONCLUSION.
AND I AGREE WITH CAITLIN, A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARE GETTING TIRED BUT
THEY ARE NOT GETTING TIRED
BECAUSE OF THE SEARCH, THEY ARE
NOT STOMACH GETTING TIRED
BECAUSE THEY DON'T SEE ANY HARD
EVIDENCE.
THEY ARE SPINNING THEIR WHEELS.
THE PAGES TODAY ARE SORT OF
INTERESTING, THEY GIVE MORE
DETAIL AND GRANULARITY, BUT WE
KNEW FROM DONALD TRUMP JR.'S
EMAIL WHAT HE WENT TO THIS
MEETING TO SEE.
SO I'M NOT SURE THAT MATERIALLY
IT ADDS.
WHAT WE REALLY DON'T KNOW IS WHY
AND WHEN THE FBI LAUNCHED THE
INVESTIGATION.
WE KNOW WHAT THEY SAY BUT WE ARE
NOT YET CLEAR ON WHY.
>> Bret: AND THE VACUUM OF ALL
THIS, THE PRESIDENT'S POLL
NUMBERS ARE GOING UP.
>> WHILE RIGHT.
BUT THEY HAVEN'T FOUND ANY
EVIDENCE OF THE MAIN ATTACK
AGAINST HIM, SO YOU WOULD EXPECT
THAT.
PLUS IF THE ECONOMY IS GETTING
BETTER, WHY WOULDN'T IT GO UP?
>> Bret: NORTH KOREA, IT LOOKS
LIKE IT'S TOUCH AND GO ON TO
WHETHER THIS SUMMIT IS HAPPENING
OR NOT.
YOUR THOUGHTS, YOU'VE BEEN
AROUND THE BLOCK WITH THE
NORTH KOREANS.
THEY DON'T REALLY KEEP UP WITH
PROMISES ALL THE TIME.
>> I'VE BEEN A CYNIC ALL ALONG
BECAUSE I LOOKED THROUGH IT
BEFORE.
I'VE SEEN NORTH KOREA LIE AND
DECEIVE, SAY THEY WILL STOP
ENRICHING URANIUM ONLY TO START
ENRICHING PLUTONIUM.
THEY WILL SAY WE HAVE GOTTEN RID
OF OUR NUCLEAR WEAPONS BUT THEY
HAVE 50 MORE.
THEY GET RID OF TEN AND KEEP 50.
THIS IS NORTH KOREA.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD
PROCEED WITH THE MILITARY DRILL
OF SOUTH KOREA.
DO NOT BACK DOWN BECAUSE IF YOU
BACKED DOWN 1 INCH, THEY WILL
ROLL ALL OVER YOU.
BE TOUGH AND FERMENT, AND I
EXPECT OF THE SUMMIT GOES ON, BE
TOUGH AND BE FIRM THERE.
BUT THE REAL ISSUE WILL BE
MONTHS AFTER AN AGREEMENT IF ONE
IS REACHED BECAUSE IN THE
HISTORY OF NORTH KOREA, THEY
SO THE PAGEANTRY OF AN AGREEMENT
IS NOT AS IMPORTANT AS
NORTH KOREA DOING WHAT THEY SAY.
>> Bret: DOESN'T HAPPEN?
>> IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT IS VERY CLEAR THAT HE
WANTS TO MAKE SOME KIND OF DEAL
HERE.
HE HASN'T DRIVEN IN LARGE PART
BY BEING ABLE TO DO THINGS.
HE SAYS THAT HIMSELF, AND HE HAS
ALSO INVITED CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THE KNOW ABOUT PEACE PRIZE.
SO I'M WONDERING HOW THAT PLAYS
INTO HOW NORTH KOREA PLAYS INTO
THIS KNOWING THEY CAN EXERT
LEVERAGE.
>> Bret: PERCENTAGE OF
SINGAPORE, JUNE 12TH.
>> I THINK 90%, IT'S ALWAYS IN
THE NORTH KOREANS INTEREST TO
MEET.
THEY MAKE AN AGREEMENT THAT THEY
DON'T FREQUENTLY ABIDE BY.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE TO KEEP THAT
OUR EYE ON THE BALL AND THE BALL
HERE IS NOT LETTING THEM GET TO
THE CAPACITY TO STRIKE THE
UNITED STATES WITH A NUCLEAR
SOUL.
AND IN A WAY, IT'S
DONALD TRUMP'S REDLINE.
WHERE WE ARE, BECAUSE HE'S BEEN
TOUGH, I AM GLAD THAT JOHN
BOLTON IS THERE.